my name is Tom I'm 31 and I'm really
excited to watch The Flash we've been
studying Tom for about a year now and he
is without a doubt the most disturbing
subject I've ever studied a lot of
people feel obligated to watch The Flash
because they don't want to miss out on
connections to future DC films is that
what you feel obligated no I just
want to watch The Flash
I don't understand I don't watch a lot
of superhero movies but I saw a trailer
for The Flash on TV and I thought that
looks really good so you want to see it
just for Michael Keaton as Batman oh is
he in this Jesus
what about the allegations and crimes of
Ezra Miller does that bother you who is
Ezra Miller researched his house for
signs of unusual behavior but he mostly
appeared to be a normal person until we
discovered something did you know that
your computer is not connected to the
internet yeah that was intentional
that's
I kind of respect that